imani 22 has died
the arnaby singer was 22.
[Music]
imani's cause of death has not yet been
revealed on thursday imani's record
producer and close friend j main
confirmed the news to e.t and said in a
statement quote imani 22 was a wonderful
individual that literally brightened up
any room she was in i worked on music
with her and helped her put together her
last project which was the color red he
went on to say quote the way we worked
together was effortless we just
understood each other it hurts so bad to
know that the last time i saw her was
the last time i'd ever see her again
i considered her to be like a little
sister to me
she will be missed and never forgotten
and i'll always think about the great
times we had hanging out
[Music]
someone else who saw her as a sister
fellow musician and friend bad baby the
rapper shared a sweet photo of the two
together on instagram and in the caption
she wrote about how she was speechless
over imani's death writing quote i used
to spend almost every day with you you
taught me so many things you are my
inspiration for many things hair nails
style etc my big sister i'm gonna miss
you so much
[Music]
imani 22 born imani johnson was a star
on the rise the singer was best known
for her songs drip-o-matic feelings and
inside which features rapper trippy read
[Music]
last year imani gave fans a
behind-the-scenes glimpse into her music
career in a video series titled a day in
the life
in the clip the singer shares her
excitement for her music and how much
she loved making it